heute fahre ich zur christian lindner
partei oder wie die alten leute sagen
fdp ihr seid davon heute show natürlich
also wir bieten euch immer wieder neue
anlässe oder das stimmt auf jeden fall
aus wie fanden sie hat herr lindner vom
bund geregelt mit der jamaika koalition
was ich bis jetzt gehört habe sie ja
vernünftig ja also sehen lieber von
aggro korrigiert zu werden
ja sag ich mal so dass ich bin wenn sie
auch wissen und gewissen fdp eine
regierung so gut kann das ja nicht
werden das sich so ja und ich denke die
in zeitung von über richtig
danke für die groko kranke für die groko
eine grundwerte aufgeben muss dann ist
eine regierung für uns nicht machbar
danke für die große frage für was nicht
geht geht nicht nur sommer das früher
abbrechen als nachher sich vier jahre
durch dejagah innerhalb der legislatur
abzubrechen
ich wollte einfach mal sagen ich find's
cool dass die fdp endlich wieder die bet
erstmal der fatah-partei es macht schon
spaß da und vernünftigen konzept so weit
würde ich jetzt nicht gehen
viele grundwerte der fdp waren in dem
papier nicht mehr lesbar ja zum beispiel
wir fallen wir jetzt nicht so viele
grundwerte ein außer besserverdiener
fördern
das sagen sie ab wann gilt man den abend
bei der fdp so 50.000 monatseinkommen
oder dahin ab 15 millionen und hole das
einkommen einstandspreise der
verständlich also ist mein arm in dem
augenblick im scherz schneiden wir weg
das habe ich schon wieder ja das war mir
schon klar wen ich mal ein jährlicher
moment was mich interessiert wie wollen
sie haben deutschen helfen
wir wollen allen deutschen helfen indem
ihr das machen was wir bisher auch
gemacht haben indem wir es hilft den
herrn nicht jeder könnte bosch konzern
heute hat schon vor 1900 gesagt mir geht
es deshalb so gut weil ich meine leute
gut bezahle und es werden ja vielleicht
für die fdp auch mal gut so was wieder
stärker noch in den vordergrund zu
rücken
aber fdp wähler wäre ja eher der bosch
gewesen und nicht die beschäftigten
dass der frontmann der fdp der
verkörpert diese politik und dem will
ich sie werden ja heute als nachfolger
von herrn lindner voraussichtlich
gewählt da das entscheidet der parteitag
wir haben gedacht wir brauchen wir
jemanden der so unterhielt die frisur
hat die oli welke und vielleicht ist das
ja man muss er dann nach oben noch ein
bisschen was ab bisschen was aber machen
sie gucken wir machen ja was ist ihre
qualifikation für den posten sehen sie
gut aus dem schwarz weiß ich weiß nicht
ob ich gut aus dem schwarz weiß ja ja ja
nicht um jeden preis und das was da auf
dem tisch lag das war eine regierung die
wir nicht verantworten können
sie sprechen die erfahrungen beim
bildungsföderalismus die konkurrenz
zwischen den 16 ländern
das wollen wir verändern dazu gab es
keine bereitschaft und dann können wir
auch nicht mitmachen ich merke wir sind
auf verschiedenen ebenen
dann breche ich das gespräch lieber ist
es besser nicht zu reden als falsch
zerstören so ziemlich in die wege macht
nichts alleine sieht man ob des sv
dessau